gary stevenson is a former city trader
and a member of patriotic millionaires
uk one of the signatories petitioning uh
rishi sunak gary this is an unusual
situation you have to admit um what
prompted
you and your uh colleagues on the list
the 30 uk millionaires to put together
this letter what prompted it
well i've been a member of this group
for a while now i mean for me personally
i've been i'm a former trader uh when i
worked in the city basically and i made
my money by betting that we wouldn't
have a strong recovery from 2008 because
we wouldn't fix inequality so i've been
very interested in this for a long time
as soon as covid happens because of my
background i was very interested in
what's going to happen to inequality
here and i could see very quickly there
was going to be an explosion in
inequality basically because there'd be
a huge accumulation of money with richer
people and we've seen that now there's
been a 22 increase in billionaire wealth
in this country the three richest
billionaire families have increased
their wealth by over 20 billion pounds
and yet when the government needs money
to pay for social care 10 billion a year
rather than looking to taxing the
billionaires rishi sunaku's family are
themselves billionaires has instead
chosen to raise national insurance which
affects workers earning 10 000 11 000
pounds a year i think it's crazy that
when the billionaires have made so much
money during a crisis when the country
needs money instead of going to
billionaires we go to ordinary sometimes
low-paid people and if we do that it's
going to crush the economy as well in
the longer term
gary how popular is is your position and
the position of the other signatories of
the letter because if everyone was
volunteering to pay more tax everyone
you know who was a millionaire and above
as it were then an awful lot of uh
issues in this country about unfairness
could be solved rather quickly couldn't
they
yeah i think that very much depends who
you're asking marielle so um you know i
come from a place called ilford in east
london i come from a pretty poor
background you know guys i know that i
grew up with that they're very happy
with the idea but you know also i went
to work in the city and then i went and
i studied at oxford and then i was
surrounded by a lot of millionaires and
um
i suspect if you ask them they some of
them might not be so happy with it but
um
it really depends
who you ask i think um but for me the
key question is
what happens to the economy in the
longer term
i think uh also the the important thing
is the letter emphasizes that this isn't
just a a good will gesture it's a matter
of what makes economic sense so can you
outline what a difference a wealth tax
might make to the economy and what sort
of well wealth tax you'd be proposing
yeah i mean the very simple message is
look if you give a thousand pounds to an
ordinary person that thousand pounds
will probably be spent by the end of the
year but if you give a thousand pounds
to a very wealthy person
they're going to use it to buy assets
from ordinary people so money that is in
the pockets of ordinary people gets
spent in shops
it drives the economy money that goes to
very wealthy people tends to push house
prices up because these guys buy assets
push up stocks pushes up stock prices
pushed up house prices so
at the moment we've had a crisis which
has massively
made richer the richest in society
ordinary people are struggling because
costs of basics are going up and now
their taxes are going up as well that
means lower spending and a weak recovery
so what exact policies do you think
could be introduced because i'm just
getting ready to vote for you
okay
uh well there's lots of different um
suggestions a few guys have come out
there was a wealth tax commission done
at lse by a couple of guys called aaron
advani and larry summers they suggested
a one-off wealth tax on people with
maybe worth over 2 million pounds or
perhaps what's over 1 million pounds
there's a world tax currently coming in
in the us which is focusing on you know
billionaire wealth super rich wealth um
for me i think the most important thing
is that it's not evaded by the very very
rich because i know ordinary people they
see policies like this and they think oh
yeah right you're going to say you're
taxing the riches but you're actually
going to tax us so i think the most
vital thing is that the very riches pay
this tax so when i'm asked about it i
say look i'm wealthy but i'm not super
wealthy like billionaires like richard's
next family i'll pay it as long as rishi
pays it so the most important thing is
that it hits the very very richest in
society
and i mean
with two things i mean the first is how
much money do you think it could raise
but the second i suppose there's a more
cultural thing about tax invasion which
has always puzzled me why why it's so
acceptable why it's acceptable for
someone to sit at a dinner or something
and tell you that they live in monaco
because that means they don't have to
pay any tax and you're sitting next to
them paying
the tax out of your salary that it takes
to pay for you know services like the
dustbins and the roads and and
everything else
is it a particularly british thing that
the idea that that paying taxes for the
little guys or do you think it's more
global
well
like i said my personal background i
come from quite a poor background but
now i've worked in the city and i've
been to oxford and i know richard people
i think this really depends kind of
where you come from ordinary people they
have to pay taxes it comes straight out
of their pay packet they don't have a
choice and if you ask them how do you
feel about you know the super rich like
uh you know politicians and millionaires
and billionaires avoiding taxes they all
hate it but it's become quite normalized
in in wealthy communities because
wealthy people huge amounts of them are
doing it so it's normalized for them so
i think within that very wealthy
community it's normal to avoid taxes
everybody's doing it so they're happy
about it but if you ask ordinary people
who have no choice and have to pay their
taxes
they hate it and you know it's no
surprise that millionaires are
comfortable with it because they're
massively benefiting from it
the last time that that tax rates went
up for the super rich they deserted the
country in their in their droves didn't
they do you think that's why the
government is is so reluctant to
consider a wealth tax i remember sitting
next to a minor oligarch who was
complaining about the fact that they
were going to take do you remember when
there was a 30 000 a year sort of
one-off non-dom tax that was going to be
introduced and he was absolutely
apoplectic because he said he employed
four people a cook a driver a
housekeeper and a butler i think um you
know there is huge resistance to this
isn't there do you think that's why the
government doesn't just introduce it
yeah i get this question a lot and i
think it's kind of based a little bit on
a bit of a misunderstanding of what
wealth is and what it means to be super
wealthy i think we kind of have this
sort of image in our head that that
wealthy people are just super super rich
people have like billions of pounds like
in a big black bag like a bank robber or
something but the truth is these guys
because they well yeah i mean they
probably do have large amounts of cash
but the main source of their wealth is
assets and that's property based in this
country land based in this country it
could be debt other people's debt of
people based in this country and
corporations that sell to this country
you know so
these guys if they leave their assets
are still here and we can still tax them
so i mean it's not as if these guys
disappear and all of the houses
disappear out of the country you know
the wealth exists in this country and
it's increasingly owned by a tiny
minority we can tax it and i think the
reason that we don't is perhaps more to
do with the fact that people like our
chancellor are literally billionaires
gary stevenson when are you going into
politics is my final question
um uh well i'm working on a book at the
moment and making youtube videos uh once
um i get enough support in that then
then maybe i'll make the jump we'll see
okay well come back and talk to me about
your book thank you very much that was
gary stevenson of the patriotic
millionaires uk
housing could be so much more affordable
wages could be so much higher and we
could have so many more options in how
we live our lives some of them put a lot
of money into paying economists and
think tanks to tell you that inequality
is important for the economy that is not
true
[Music]
you